[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النشره والتغطيه
لنتائج الانتخابات التركيه التي اظهرت
النتائج الاوليه فيها حتى الان تقدما
للرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان على منافسه من
مرشح تحالف المعارضه كمال وذلك بعد فرز
نحو 79% من الانتخابات وبحسب مصادر تركيا
فقط حصل اردوغان على 50% من الاصوات مقابل
43 بالمئه فقط
اعلنت تقدمه عبر تويتر فيما نفى الحزم
الحاكم بقياده اردوغان هذا التقدم وها هو
الان باخر تحديث حزب العداله والتنميه
التركي الحاكم يقول باننا متقدمون في
نتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه
وكما نشاهد الارقام اردوغان حاصل حتى الان
على 50%
على
43.70 بالمئه ونسبه الفرز حتى الان تقترب
من الثمانين بالمئه
[موسيقى]
صرح رئيس بلديه اسطنبول والمرشح لمنصب
نائب الرئيس اكرم امام اوغلو بان البيانات
الحاليه تظهر انك سيكون الرئيس حيث طالب
رئيس بلديه اسطنبول المنتمي للمعارضه طالب
الاتراك بعدم متابعت نتائج الانتخابات من
وكاله الاناضول التابعه للدوله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وينضم الينا شبكات مراسلينا من اسطنبول
كريستيان بيسري مفردات العربيه ومن غازي
عنتاب ايضا عبد القادر خربوش اهلا بك ما
ابدا معك كريستيانو يعني اخر التحديثات
بما يخص النتائج طبعا باسطنبول المهمه جدا
للطرفين
اهلا بك يا راضيه وبالمشاهدين اذا نحن
نتابع واياكم عمليات فارس النتائج من
مقر حزب الشعب الجمهوري
لمرشحه كمال كالشتار اوغلو اتى او توافد
المؤيدون الى هنا لمتابعه هذه النتائج قبل
ان اتابعها مع كراويه اود ان اشير الى ما
قاله المرشح للرئاسه سنان اوغان في تغريده
عبر تويتر الان
ارى اننا امام جوله ثانيه ادعو القوميين
والاتى تركيين لحمايه الاصوات ولنستعد معا
لهذه الجوله هو الذي يحصل على اكثر من 5%
من الاصوات يمكن ان نرى نتائج الان راويه
على الشاشه حيث متابعها
مع مؤيدي المعارضه بحسب وكاله الاناضول
فان اردوغان بعد فرز ثمانين فاصل خمسه
بالمئه من صناديق الاقتراع يحصل على
50.43%
وكمال كريشتار اوغلو على
43.77
نتيجه الاخير سنان اوغان التي الذي تحدث
عن جوله ثانيه اتت نوعا ما مفاجئه لانه لم
يكن يتوقع ان يحصل على هذه النسبه
وبالتالي يقال كلما ارتفعت نسبه التصويت
الاصوات التي يحصل عليها فاننا سنكون
تلقائيا امام جوله ثانيه نذكر بانه المرشح
عن حزب اجدادنا الذي القومي اليميني
المتطرف الذي يدعو الى مغادره اللاجئين
والمهاجرين من تركيا للحفاظ على هويتها
القوميه
كنت وابد ان اشير الان انه اظهرت نتائج
وكاله انقى المعارضه
ارقاما مختلفه نراها ايضا على هذه الشاشه
راويه حتى الان لا ارقام دقيقه يعني وكاله
الاناضول تتحدث بارقام وكاله انقى
المعارضه تتحدث بارقام وكذلك يعني
المسؤولون عن كل طرف عن كل فريق
يسوقنا بانهم يستعدون للاحتفال بالنصر
ولكن الواقع على الارض يعني والارقام لا
تؤكد بعد هذا الموضوع يعني احد مفاجات هذه
الانتخابات هو السنان اوغان الذي حصل على
نسبه كبيره من التصويت اكثر من مليونين
تركي صوتوا لهذا الرجل
نتحدث عنه راويه بان هذا يعكس مزاج الشعب
التركي الذي فعلا يريد يعني ان يرحل
اللاجئون والمهاجرون لانه رئيس حزب
اجدادنا حسب قومي يميني متشدد يعني يريد
الحفاظ يريد لتركيا ان تحافظ على قوميتها
وبالتالي النسبه العاليه التي اقترعت له
فعلا تعكس يعني مزاج الشارع التركي بينما
الارقام الاخرى يعني تاتي نوعا ما متوقعه
مع العلم بانه المفارقه هنا لانه حتى
الوكاله التي تنطق باسم المعارضه وقالت
الانقى التي تقول بانك يتقدم حتى ارقامها
نرى بانه التقدم حتى الان
نشا الطيب اردوغان نعم وبالتالي يعني هنا
هناك غير مفهومه وعندما يعني نسال عنها
يقولون بنسال لماذا المسؤولين عن الحزب او
عن المعارضه يقولون بانه متقدم مع العلم
بان الوكاله التابعه لهم تقول العكس
يقولون نحن ناتي بارقامنا من المراقبين
داخل صناديق داخل مراكز الاقتراع الذين
يفرزون من الداخل ولذلك هي ارقام اكثر دقه
والان كريستيانو يعني اردوغان يقول بانه
اعلان النتائج بصوره متسرعه يؤدي الى سرقه
اراده الشعب اذا اردوغان يحذر من سرقه
اراده الشعب وانتقل الى موفدنا الى غازي
عنتاب عبد القادر خربوش عبد القادر ماذا
عن التحديثات حيث تتواجد انت
تقريبا هي نسب نفسها التي كنا نتحدث عنها
قبل اقل من ساعه من الان نلاحظ ان النتائج
التي يحققها
رجب طيب اردوغان تتراجع ولو بنسبه ضئيله
بين الفينه والاخرى فيما يتقدم غريمه
ايضا ولوتيره بطيئه هو الاخر في حين ايضا
يرتفع ترتفع حصه سنان اوغان ايضا بنسب
متقدمه احيانا وبطيئه احيانا اخرى ولكن
هذا التراجع لرجل رجب طيب اردوغان والتقدم
لمنافسين يجعل احتماليه الذهاب نحو جوله
ثانيه جدا يعني مطروحه الان بجديه اذا لم
يتم الحسم بنتيجه بنتيجه 50 يعني زائد
واحد بالمئه فستتجه الانت الرئاسيه نحو
الحسم في جوله ثانيه وهذا يعني بدات تصريح
به الان في هذه المناطق حيث اتواجد
بالجنوب التركي تقريبا هي نفس النسبه
تتراوح رجب طيب اردوغان يتصدر المشهد مثلا
في هاتاي الى حد الان بعد فرز حوالي قرابه
80% من صناديق الاقتراع بخمسين فاصل تسعه
بالمئه فيها اقول متبوع
بنسبه 45% وايضا سنان اوغان ب 8.7 بالمئه
وهذا ما يدفعني الى القول لما تحدثت عنه
كريستيانو حول تنامي خطاب يعني
التطرف نوعا ما تجاه لاجئين تحديدا في
هاته المناطق الجنوبيه الحدوديه مع سوريا
حيث يتواجد اعداد كبيره من اللاجئين
السوريين كان لنا كانت لنا لقاءات عديده
اليوم مع كبيره منهم سواء المجنسين الذين
يحق لهم التصويت او حتى غير المجنسين
الذين وجدناهم يقولون بانهم يعانون من
كثير من المشاكل والمتاعب خصوصا في الاونه
الاخيره ومخاوفهم تزداد مع زياده هذا
النوع من الخطاب المتطرف الذي يستهدفهم
بالخصوص من المعارضه او من اليمين المتطرف
الذي لا يرغب بتواجدهم على ارض تركيا
بغازي عنتاب حيث اتواجد غير بعيد الان
تصلني بعض الصور لبدء انصار حزب العداله
والتنميه بالاحتفالات على الاقل بفوزه
العريض هنا بغازي عنتاب باكثر من نصف
الاصوات ونصف نسبه الاصوات الى حد الساعه
وفق النتائج الاوليه لكن هذا لا يرجح الكف
عموما لفوزه في بحسم الجوله الاولى في
باقي الولايات الاخرى ونتابع بين الفينه
والاخر على التحديثات التي تطرا على هذه
النتائج ولو على تباينها من وكاله الى
اخرى الى حين ان تتضح الصوره اكثر نعم قبل
ان انتقل الى مفادنا ايضا زيدان زنكلو اود
ان اعود اليك كريستانيا يعني تحدثني عن
مزاج الناخب التركي ما الذي تحكم به هل
يعني الوضع الاقتصادي المتردي في البلاد
ام يعني
الرغبه في التغيير ام هويه تركيا الدينيه
ان كانت علمانيه ام مسلمه
يمكن القول كل هذه العوامل مجتمعه بحسب اي
فئه نتحدث عنها يعني مؤيد اردوغان بطبيعه
الحال
يعني اهمهم الاول هو الحفاظ على وجه تركيا
المحافظ الاسلامي على القيم التي يقولون
بانها تمثلهم ولا يعايرون اهميه كبيره
بالنسبه للازمه الاقتصاديه ولو انهم يقرون
بها وبانهم يرزحون تحت وطاطاتها حتى ان ما
لاحظناه خلال جولاتنا على مراكز الاقتراع
اليوم بان اعمار المؤيدين الذين توجهوا
الى صناديق الاقتراع هم متوسطي العمر يعني
40 وما فوق
عندما سالناهم عن دوافعهم لانتخابه قالوا
باننا عيشنا مرحلتين ما قبل اردوغان في
الحكم وما بعده وراينا الفرق هناك
الانجازات كثيره حققها هذا الرجل ولا يمكن
ان نتوقف عند الازمه الاقتصاديه
الطارئه والمؤقته التي يمكن ان تحل
واكثر ذهب وابعد من ذلك بالقول لا يمكننا
ان ننتخب المعارضه منهم من قال بان تحمل
في طياتها
اطياف تريد تقسيم تركيا ومنهم من قال
بانها لا تحمل مبادئ المجتمع المحافظ
وطبعا هذا فيه يعني صدى لما قاله اردوغان
في حملته الانتخابيه في اخر خطاب له بان
المعارضه تشجع على الشذوذ وهي لا تشبهنا
كمجتمع تركي بينما من يريدون انتخاب او من
يعني
فكان العنوان الاول هو الحريه
والديمقراطيه واعاده الوجه العلماني
لتركيا اما الفئه التي تحدثت عن التغيير
والتي تريد ان
تنتخبلو فقط من اجل التغيير من دون ان
يكون لها هم واضح وهو البرنامج هم فئه
الشباب الذين حقيقه لم لهم حضور قوي وكثيف
في هذه الانتخابات يعني حوالي سته ملايين
او لنقل خمسه ملايين و500 الف شاب من
الجيل زاد الذين ينتخبون للمره الاولى كان
من المتوقع ان يقبل بكثافه على صناديق
الاقتراع ولكن لم نلحظ ذلك اليوم يعني
كانت الفئه العمريه كما ذكرنا اربعين
وبالتالي
بحسب الانتماء الحزبي يمكن القول بانه كان
الدوافع من وراء الانتخاب مجرد يعني ان
تعرفي الى اي حزب ينتمي وبالتالي يمكنك
بسهوله ان تدركي على اي اساس ينتخب ابقي
معنا كريستيانو وانتقل الى مفدى زيدان
زنكلو من انقره زيدان يعني الان اردوغان
يقول بانه على الاتراك عدم ترك صناديق
الاقتراح حتى اعلان النتائج بشكل رسمي وهي
نقطه شدد عليها كليتش دار اوغل و وايضا
سنان اوغان بانه يجب عدم ترك صناديق
الاقتراع هل هنالك من معلومات ربما او
مؤشرات عن
الامور التي تحصل عاده في الانتخابات
اخفاء صناديق ام التزوير ام شيء من هذا
القبيل
[موسيقى]
نعم عاده عندما يعلن مرشح مرشح ما فوق
الفوز في الانتخابات
مراقبي
الاحزاب التي تناهد هذا الحزب مثلا على
سبيل المثال في الانتخابات في عمليه
الاستفتاء على الدستور عندما اعلن الرئيس
رجب طيب الدكان في عام 2017
موافقه الشعب التركي او تقدم الاشخاص
الذين وافقوا على تعديل الدستور بنسبه
تجاوزت الخمسين في المئه قيل من بعض وسائل
الاعلام ان مراقبيه حزب الشعب الجمهوري
تركته صناديق الاقتراع وغادروا مراكز
الاقتراح لذلك الرئيس التركي يريد التاكيد
على مراقبيه حزب العداله والتنميه
والمراقبين من تحالف الشعب بالبقاء في
مراكز في مراكزهم وايضا هذه هذه اللسان
حادلو منعا لاي يعني اخفاء لبعض الاصوات
او
يعني موضوع التزوير في حال كان هناك
احتماليه لذلك هناك تجديد من كلا الجانبين
على هذه النقطه تحديدا الرئيس اردوغان
وهنا هنا اعيد تصريح الرئيس اردوغان قال
اطلب من جميع اصدقائي وزملائي البقاء في
صناديق الاقتراع مهما حدث حتى يتم
الانتهاء من النتائج رسميا نحن دخلنا الان
في
نتحدث ربما الساعه الاخيره نسبه الاصوات
التي تم فرزها في عموم تركيا وصلت الى
85.89 باقي اقل من 5% من اصوات الناخبين
النسبه الان تشير الى
50.27% اي ان النسبه الرئيس التركي تتراجع
في المقابل كمال كلجدار اوبلو حصل على
43.93% بينما سنان اوغان حصل على خمسه
فاصله
هذا فيما يخص النسبه العامه اتحدث هنا عن
انقره حيث نتواجد هنا في العاصمه التركيه
اخر تحديث ساحاول ان اطلع عليه طبعا في
نسبه المشاركه وهنا معلومه ايضا نسبه
المشاركه في عموم تركيا حتى الان
88.32% فيما يخص العاصمه التركيه انقره تم
فرز
84.5% نسبه المشاركه وصلت الى
90.90% تقريبا 91% حتى الان الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان يتقدم ب
47.26% بواقع مليون و519 الف صوت
و144
صوت بالنسبه لمرشح المعارضه كمال كل جدار
اوغلو حصل على
45.91
بواقع مليون و475 الف صوت تقريبا
بالنسبه الى المرشح الرئاسي الثالث وهو
سنان اوغان حصل على 6.44 بواقع
الاف صوت هذه هي مجمل التفاصيل التي تحصل
او تحدث الان في انقره طبعا في معسكر
المعارضه وسال اعلان تركيا تحدثت عن ان
قاده تحالف الطاوله السداسيه سينتقلون او
انتقلوا الى مقر تحالف او مقر حزب الشعب
الجمهوري هنا في العاصمه التركيه لمتابعه
نتائج الانتخابات كما ذكرت نحن في
الساعه الحاسمه لا نتحدث عن ساعات ساعه
حاسمه اقل من 5% من اصوات الناخبين ربما
ستبقي الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان في منصبه
كرئيس بمنصب
لتركيا او نذهب باتجاه انتخابات الاعاده
على اعتبار ان احتمال يعني ان يتقدم كل
جدار اوبلو الى اكثر من 50% اعتقد انها
باتت صعبه وربما صعبه جدا لذلك اما الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغ ان سيبقى بمنصبه كرئيس
للجمهوريه التركيه او سنذهب الى جوله
ثانيه من الانتخابات وهذا ما صرح به سنان
اوغان قبل قليل قال انه هناك احتماليه
احتماليه الذهاب الى بدانا نرى احتماليه
الذهاب الى جوله ثانيه في هذه الانتخابات
زيدان يعني هذا ما يرجحه اغلب المراقبين
الذهاب الى جوله ثانيه وننوه الى الاخبار
العاجله الان نقلا عن الذي يقول بانه
النسب الخياليه التي اظهرت حصول اردوغان
على 60% تراجعت الى 50% وشدد على ضروره
عدم ترك المراقبين مراقبي الانتخابات
لمواقعهم وبانه
يجب عدم اذن تارك صناديق الاقتراحات اعلان
النتائج الرسميه اعود الى غازي عنتاب
ومفدى عبد القادر خربوش عبد القادر يعني
هل من تحديثات حول النتائج حتى الان وايضا
على اي اساس انتخب الاتراك بغازي عنتاب
التحديثات الان دائما في منحه تنازلي
بالنسبه لرجب طيب اردوغان وتصاعدي بالنسبه
لغريمه كمالك ما يجعلنا نقترب شيئا فشيئا
نحو جوله ثانيه من هذه الانتخابات للحسم
فيها اذا استمرت على الاقل هذه النتائج
بهذه الوتيره حيث تم يعني الفرز في عموم
تركيا الى حد الساعه باثنين وخمانين فاصله
خمسه بالمئه من صناديق الاقتراع حيث بلغت
نسبه فوز او تتقدم رجب طيب اردوغان الى حد
الساعه خمسين فاصل ثلاثه يعني اذا بلغت
نسبه
الفرز الصناديق 90% واستمر في النزول بهذا
الشكل فسيفقد نسبه اكثر من 50% وبذلك
سنتجه مباشره نحو الجوله الثانيه الا اذا
حدث العكس والا اذا كانت هذه الارقام غير
دقيقه مثل ما يتم تداول الاتهامات بين
الطرفين بين انصار
المتنافسين البارزين لهذا الانتخاب
بالعوده الى سؤالك على اي اساس تم
الانتخاب رغم ان نسبه المشاركه كانت كبيره
جدا وتجاوزت 80% بل قاربت التسعين في
المئه في عديد الولايات هنا بالجنوب كما
في باقي الولايات الاخرى فهناك عده
اعتبارات هناك الاعتبارات الاقتصاديه التي
اثقلت كاهل المواطن التركي خلال السنوات
الاخيره سواء من الداعمين
للرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان او المناوين له
المعارضين له فمن يدعمون اردوغان يعتبرون
بان الازمه الاقتصاديه والتضخم وانخفاض
القدره الشرائيه مرتبط بعده عوامل خارجه
عن اطار سياسه حكم الرئيس الذي نهض
بالبلاد خلال عقدين من حكمه بصفه جدريه
وتقدم بها اشواطا كبيره نحو عديد يعني
معالم التطور لهذا البلد على الاقل في
المناحي الاقتصاديه الكبرى والصناعات
العسكريه ودورها المحوري في المنطقه في
اوروبا وحتى في كثير من النزاعات حول
العالم اما المعارضين له فيعتبرون بان
سنوات الاخيره على الاقل الخمس سنوات
الاخيره والتراجع الاقتصاد يمثل فشلا
للنظام حكم يقولون بانه لم يعد يقدم
البديل يعني يستجيب لتطلعات الشارع التركي
الذي اصبح يرى البلد والتطور بعين اخرى
غير التي يراها انصار الحزب الحاكم ولذلك
هناك تقارب في يعني هذا هذه النسبه وهذه
النتائج الى حد الساعه نرى بانه لا يوجد
فارغ كبير من حيث النتائج ومن حيث انصار
رجب طيب اردوغان وايضا منافسه كمالك
الجدار اوغلو ما يجعل هذه المنافسه
متقاربه جدا وما يضعها مثل ما قلت وفق
الكثير من المراقبين ووفق هذه الارقام
التي نستقيها او نتابعها كل لحظه بان يعني
حسم هذا الصراع السياسي وهذا السباق
المحتدم خلال هذا هذه الانتخابات الاكثر
اهميه في تاريخ هذا البلد والذي هي تؤسس
الى عهد جديد لهذا البلد الذي يعني احتفل
بمئويته مئويه تاسيس الدوله التركيه
الحديثه يعني بعد مده قصيره جدا ولذلك هي
تحظى باهتمام كبير سواء بالنسبه للداخل
التركي وحتى بالنسبه
للدول المحيطه المجاوره وكبرى الدول التي
اولت اهتماما كبيرا لهذه الانتخابات اذا
شبكات مراسله العربيه ارجو
تفضل بالبقاء معنا نعود لنذكر اذا بنتائج
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه فقد اظهرت
النتائج ان مرشح تحالف المعارضه كمال
كليتشدار اوغلو قد قلص الفارقه بينه وبين
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان وذلك بعد فرز 82%
من الاصوات وذكر الاعلام الرسمي التركي ان
اردوغان حصل على 50% من الاصوات مقابل 43
بالمئه
في النتائج الاوليه حيث الان المرشح كمال
كريتش دار اوغلو يقول لن ننام الليله
واعود اليك كريستيانو بيصري يعني كيف
تصفين كريستيان تنظيم هذه الانتخابات
تامينها وسرعه فرز الاصوات
حقيقه كانت انتخابات سلسه لم تسجل اي
خروقات حقيقيه تذكر كان هناك بعض المشكلات
الطفيفه التي
رايناها في مراكز الاقتراع التي شلنا
عليها ولكن سرعان ما كانت تحل في الداخل
من قبل المراقبين هناك من حيث التامين
نشرت وزاره الداخليه حوالي 600 الف رجل من
الشرطه والجيش لتامين هذه الانتخابات ولكن
لم يكن حضورهم واضحا يعني لم نكن نرى
انتشارا كثيفا لرجال الامن ونحن نجول في
اسطنبول على مراكز الاقتراع وبالتالي كانت
العمليه سلسه وهادئه بالرغم من
يبدو ان يتم التحذير عنها نعم نعم يبدو ان
لدينا مشكله بالصوت معك كريستيانو ساعود
اليك بعد قليل انتقل الى زيدان زنكلو
زيدان يعني يبدو ان هناك عدم ثقه كبيره من
المعارضه بالارقام الرسميه حتى انه رئيس
بلديه اسطنبول والمرشح لمنصب نائب الرئيس
اكرم امام اوغلو طلب عدم متابعه نتائج
الانتخابات الصادره عن وكاله الاناضول
نعم لا شك ان اكرم رئيس بلديه اسطنبول
يعني لديه
التي توقفت في عام 2019 عن بيانات
الانتخابيه بعد ان
تقدم على مرشح الحزب الحاكم بن علي البرنس
واله النتيجه لصالح توقفت حينها وكاله
الاناضول عن النشر ومنذ ذلك الحين اكثر
ومنذ ذلك الحين ومنذ ذلك الحين اكثر
الامام اوكلو ينتقد وكاله اندول واليوم
مجددا يعيد هذا الموضوع في مقابل طبعا
مسؤولين من حزب العداله والتنميه انتقدوا
اكثر على تصريحاته التي قال فيها او التي
انتقد فيها وكاله الاندول وقال انه استعجل
باعلان الرئيس ووصفه كمالك برئيس تركيا
لكن بالعموم النتائج تتغير يعني وصلنا الى
اكثر من
87% من نسبه الاصوات التي تم فرزها الرئيس
اردوغان في المقدمه بخمسين فاصله سبعه
عفوا 17% اي ان النسبه تراجعت نوعا ما
الرئيس في المقابل الان النسبه
50.2% الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان بعد فوز
87.73% كل جدار اوغلو مرشح المعادله تقدم
بنقطه واحده واصبح 44 بالمئه سنان اوغان
50. عفوا خمسه فاصله
31% 50 تنهي الانتخابات
5.31% لسنان اوغان هذا فيما يخص
الانتخابات الرئاسيه تحدثنا كثيرا عنها
لكن نعرج قليلا ان كان لدي بعض الوقت على
الانتخابات البرلمانيه حيث تم فرز
878.34% من الاصوات حتى الان حزب العداله
والتنميه او عفوا تحالف الشعب الذي يقوده
حزب العداله والتنميه وصل الى
50.99% تقريبا 51% بواقع 325 مقعد في
البرلمان اي انه ما زال يملك الاغلبيه حتى
الان
بالنسبه لتحالف الامه الان هناك تحديث وصل
الى
34.25 بواقع
216 مقعدا بالنسبه يتحالف العمل والحريه
الذي يقوده الشعوب الديمقراطي الكردي وصل
الى
9.33% بواقع 59 مقعد في البرلمان هذه نسبه
الانتخابات البرلمانيه وكما قلت تم فرز
78.34% ايضا هناك نقطه اخرى ربما قد تغير
بشكل طفيف نتائج الانتخابات وهي اصوات
الاتراك في الخارج وقد وصلني قبل قليل انه
تم فرز 25% من اصوات الناخبين الاتراك
الذين صوتوا في الخارج وكان بلغ عدد
المصوطين مليون و800 الف عاده اردوغان في
الانتخابات الماضيه والتي سبقتها يحوز
النسبه الاغلب من الاصوات الاتراك في
الخارج لكن في هذه الانتخابات لا نعلم كيف
ستكون النسبه بالعموم حتى الان احتمال
الذهاب الى جوله ثانيه ما زال قائما
اقل من
13% من اصوات
انا كنت قلت قبل قليل بقي خمسه في المئه
كنت مخطئ اقل من 13% من الصناديق
ستفرز خلال وقت قصير وبالتالي نعرف ما هي
النتيجه النهائيه للانتخابات وضعنا
لماذا يجب ان تعلن النتائج قبل الساعه
الثانيه عشره ليلا
[موسيقى]
نعم جرت العاده في تركيا ان اعلان النتائج
شبه النهائيه ولا نتحدث عن النتائج
النهائيه يعني بعد فرص اكثر من 90% من
الاصوات تعلن قبل حلول الساعه الثانيه
عشره ليلا هذا هو التقليد المتبع هنا في
تركيا لكن النتائج النهائيه
يتم اعلانها من قبل رئيس اللجنه العليا
للانتخابات بشكل رسمي في وقت لاحق ربما
بعد يوم او يومين بعد ان نظر في الطعون
المقدمه من الاحزاب
على مستوى البرلمان او حتى على مستوى
الرئاسه بعد النظر في كل الطعون ومعالجه
هذه الطعون يتم اعلان النتائج النهائيه
لكن ليس في نفس اليوم لك ربما بعد يوم
نشات اعلان النتائج النهائيه
زيدان وانت
نشاهد هذه الجموع وراءك تحتفل طبعا نذكر
بانه اردوغان المسيطر على مقاليد الحكم في
تركيا منذ 21 عاما يخوض هذه الانتخابات
بمواجهه كمال كليتش دار اوغلو عن تحالف
الامه وايضا سنان اوغان مرشح تحالف او
الاجداد القومي اعود الى عبد القادر خربوش
عبد القادر يعني ما ابرز ما يعني لاحظتوا
او تم تسجيله في هذه العمليه في هذا اليوم
الانتخابي الطويل خلال جولتك على مراكز
الاقتراع ما ابرز ملفتك
نعم اذكر فقط ما يتم تداوله وسط وسائل
الاعلام التركيه الان بخصوص تزايد حده
التصريحات والتوتر وسط المتنافسين خصوصا
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان وايضا كمالكيجار
تحديدا الذي بدا مهددا لهيئه العليا
للانتخابات بقوله لن ننام الليله ونطالبكم
ان تنشروا الارقام الصحيحه دون تحريف كما
طالب ايضا
مسؤوليه الانتخابات البقاء بمراكز الفرز
ونبه الى مساله قال بانه لا يجب مساله
ادخال البيانات على مستوى المحافظات فهي
حده
التصريحات والتوتر تزداد كانت هناك تداول
ايضا لخبر لا ندري ان كان صحيحا
بشكل يعني دقيق ام لا وهو فيما يتعلق
باميرال اكشنر التي قيل بانها فقدت
اعصابها صفعت احد يعني اطارات حزبها وقالت
الم اقل لكم باننا سنخسر ولا نفوز في هذه
الانتخابات هذا ما يتداول وسط وسائل
الاعلام التركيه اعود الى سؤالك وما
لاحظته من خلال تغطيه للانتخابات
الرئاسيه التركيه لاول مره في مسار المهني
لاحظت بان هناك يعني تنظيم محكم جدا
للانتخابات لدى الاتراك خصوصا في مناطق هي
منكوبه وشبه معزوله عن العالم الاخر مثلا
التي كنت فيها منذ اول ساعه منذ فتح
المراكز اليوم كنت اتوقع ان تسير العمليه
بفوضى لكن وجدت كل شيء مرتب كله يعني كل
واحد في في مهامه الموكله اليه كان هناك
تكفل واضح ومساعده
للضحايا العائدين الى يعني الاصليه من اجل
المشاركه في هذا الاستحقاق الانتخابي
الهام جدا تخيلي يعني اعداد النازحين
الذين غادروا هذه الولايات المتضرره الى
عديد المدن الاخرى بتركيا تمكنوا من
الوصول والادلاء باصواتهم في وفق مختلف
وسائل النقل التي سخرت لذلك سواء عن طريق
الباصات الحافلات او حتى عن طريق الطيران
ووقفنا حتى على يعني تخصيص اماكن
وشاليهات مخصصه لتعويض هؤلاء القادمين
تعويضهم لانه السلطات اخذت على عاتقها
تكاليف تنقلهم من هذه الولايات الى
ولاياتهم الاصليه من اجل الادلاء باصواتهم
كذلك حتى المقيمين او القابعين في القيام
والشاليهات من ضحايا زلزال كان لهم نصيب
من المساعده بتخصيص حافلات صغيره تنقلهم
نحو مراكز الانتخاب لاحظنا ايضا
مشاعر امتزجه داخل مراكز الاقتراع بحيث
تحولت الى نقاط التقاء بين هؤلاء العائدين
الى يعني احيائهم الاصليه ومدونهم التي
غادروها منذ اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر شاهدنا من
كان يبكي ربما تذكر احبه لهم فقدوهم خلال
زلزال واخرون رايناهم يبتسمون حين التقوا
بجيرانهم وهناك حتى من اصر لنا بانه التقى
بشخص كان يعتقد انه قضى في الزلزال لكنه
التقى به في مركز انتخابي وخرج سعيدا كل
هذه الصور والمشاهد عايشناها عن قرب مع
الاتراك وهم يشاركون في يعني كتابه تاريخ
جديد لهذه الدوله التي يعني مرت بكثير من
التحديات ولا تزال تواجهها الكثير من
التحديات وهذا ما يعني يعكس هذا التقارب
الكبير في النتائج بين يعني فارسي هذا
السباق الانتخابي الهام مثل ما قلت ويجعل
الرهان اكثر والتحدي كبير ايضا امام
الرئيس الثالث عشر لتركيا
لمواجهه ينتظره من تحديات ويعني الاستجابه
للتطلعات الملايين من الاتراك عدد كبير
جدا من الناخبين يفوق 60 يعني مليون ناخب
هذا رقم كبير جدا لتاطير عمليه انتخابيه
بهذا الحجم في بلد يعني بهذا الحجم ايضا
فقد تعتبر تجربه التركيه في تنظيم
الانتخابات رائده
ويعني يحتذى بها بخصوص عندنا في الدول
العربيه لم نشاهد الخروقات التي تعودنا
عليها في كثير من الدول في تغطياتنا لم
نشاهد حقيقه هناك توتر وهناك كان تصريحات
مسبقه قبل اجراء الانتخابات كان هناك
مخاوف من رده فعل انصار كل يعني تيار
بخصوص عن النتائج لحد الان لم نشاهد اي رد
فعل عنيف هناك تحذيرات ولكن في المقابل
هناك استعداد ايضا لمواجهه ما قد يحدث
هناك تخصيص اكثر من 600 الف رجل امن
لتاطير هذه العمليه شاهدنا في مناطق
الجنوب تواجد للجيش التركي بغض النظر عن
التواجد الامني الخفيف للمتمثل في عناصر
الشرطه داخل المراكز او عندما داخل
المراكز الانتخابيه وحتى في الشوارع
بالاضافه الى عناصر الدرك وكل اجهزه الامن
بمختلف تشكيلاتها فهناك استعداد كبير جدا
لما قد تفرزه هذه الانتخابات
وطبعا للتحذيرات التي يعني ولدت على لسان
كثير من المسؤولين حتى رئيس نفسه رجب طيب
اردو المعارضه بانها قد تلجا الى اساليب
العنف وكان الرد من المعارضه ايضا بنفس
الاسلوب وهذا ما يزيد من يعني المنافسه
الشديده ومن حماس هذه المنافسه لهذه
الدرجه اعود اليك كريستيان يعني يقال بانه
اسطنبول ستكون يعني مثل امتحان للولاء
ولاءات الناس خاصه بعد ان خسر حزب العداله
والتنميه الانتخابات البلديه عام 2019 من
خلال ملاحظاتك من خلال استطلاعات الراي
وايضا من خلال النتائج الاوليه هل يمكن
الجزم مدينه اسطنبول الكبرى برمزيتها
السياسيه وايضا الاقتصاديه هي لصالح
المعارضه ام الحكومه
لا يمكن الجزم بهذا الموضوع
ولكن دعيني اشير الى ان بما انك ذكرت
انتخابات اسطنبول عام 2019 بان الرئيس
بلديه اسطنبول يتحدث للمره الثانيه في
فتره وجيزه امام اوغلو الان يتحدث
والكل يراقب ما يقول اود ان اشير راويه
الى ان بعض المصادر قالت لنا بانه تم رفع
التشكيدات الامنيه حول الهيئه العليا
للانتخابات لاعلى مستوى بعد ظهور النتائج
وهناك توقعات باعتراض الطرفين بجماهير
حاشده في ظل نتيجه عدم الحسم المستمر حتى
الان
لا تسال الفروقات على حالها حتى يعني
الوكاله المعارضه تشير الى تقدم اردوغان
على منافسه كالشتار اوكلو وكاله الاناضول
تقول بعد فرز 85% فاصل ثمانيه من الاصوات
اردوغان يحصل على
50.13% من الاصوات وكريستار اوغلو على
44,09 من الاصوات وسنان اوغان على 5% من
الاصوات هذا بالنسبه
لوكاله الاناضول وكاله الانقى التابعه
للمعارضه تقول بان اردوغان حصل على
48.73% من الاصوات بينما كمال كالشتار
اوغلو على
45.52% من الاصوات وسنان اوغان على خمسه
فاصل 32%
من الاصوات اذا
بحسب وكاله المعارضه فان الفرق بين
اردوغان
وبين كالشتار اوغلو
يتقلص تدريجيا
وهذا ما يجعل امكانيه
اللجوء الى دوره ثانيه واردا جدا
الان رئيس بلديه اسطنبول الذي نراه على
الشاشه راويه يتحدث عن ان وكاله الاناضول
التدار من قبل اجانب وليس اتراك ولذلك نحن
لا نثق بها تابعوا النتائج عبرنا عبر
وكاله انكا الاناضول فقدت الثقه في الشعب
ثقه الشعب منذ عام 2019 على هامش انتخابات
البلديات لا تمنحوها الفرصه من جديد اذا
لازلنا بنفس حرب البيانات هذه المستمره
بين الطرفين كل طرف يدعو الى متابعه وكاله
الانباء التي تمثله ويقول بانها تعطي
الارقام الادق ولكن حتى الان لا ارقام
نهائيه ومن المفترض ان تصدر الارقام
النهائيه الهيئه العليا للانتخابات وذلك
سيكون بعد ساعات والان كريستي العوده
سؤالك عن تفضلي
نعم
[موسيقى]
حتى
باطار الحديث عن بعد صناديق الاقتراع يعني
في معلومات عن انه في ديار بكر خرجت
مظاهره بسبب التنديد بعدم احتساب اصوات
صناديق تابعه
ويقال بان هناك حدا يعني حصل على حوالي
72% من الاصوات يعني اكثر
الولايات التي اعطته اصواتها هي ديار بكر
حتى اكثر من ازمير وانقره التين عاده ما
تعدان الثقل لحزب الشعب الجمهوري
وللمعارضه بشكل عام
بالعوده للحديث عن اسطنبول وعن تحدثني عن
ثقلها على الاقتصادي والسياسي يعني حتى
الان لا يمكن الجزم باي باي نتائج ولكن
الاحياء التي زرناها في اسطنبول اليوم
وشلنا على مراكز الاقتراع فيها تحدث معظم
الناخبون عن التوجه الانتخاب الرئيس رشا
الطيب اردوغان
واستعرضوا ثقتهم به بالرغم من الاسماء
الاقتصاديه
الاخيره التي عاشوها وقالوا بانها لا تزال
او هي ازمه مؤقته يمكن ان تحل
نحن اذا نتابع الان مؤتمر صحفي اخر
نعم سنكون معك كريستيانو في حال ورود اي
جديد هذه المؤتمرات بطبيعه الحال نعم نعم
نذكر باخر التحديثات اذا اردوغان حتى الان
حاصل على
50.13%
ونسبه الفرس حتى الان هي 85 بالمئه وينضم
الينا مفرد العربيه الى اسطنبول طاهر بركه
اهلا بك طاهر يعني ما هي اخر الارقام
المتوفره عندك عمده اسطنبول منذ قليل يقول
بانه كليتش دار اوغلو حصل على 49% مقابل
45% لاردوغان وبانه الاصوات الموجوده في
الصناديق هي ذاهبه
هذه الارقام لا يعترف بها راويه اهلا بك
لا يعترف بها حزب العداله والتنميه انا
هنا في المقر الرئيسي لحزب العداله
والتنميه في اسطنبول وهذه الارقام التي
على الشاشه امامي هي تقريبا كالتي ذكرتها
قبل قليل
50.13 ليردوغان بعد فرز
85.82 بالمئه نحن نتحدث عن 23 مليونا واقل
من 500 الف بقليل مقابل
44.09 لكلتش
بعشرين مليون واكثر من 5000 عشرين مليون
و600 الف واكثر بقليل او ازيد بقليل سنان
اوغان 5.1 او ثلاثه واحد بالمئه كان هناك
خبر في هذا المقر على تي ار تي خبر القناه
التي معتمده هنا كان هناك خبر يقول بانه
تم حتى الان فقط فرز 15 عشره بالمئه من
اصوات صناديق الخارج ولعلوا في هذا اشاره
الى انه النتيجه يمكن ان تتغير في اي وقت
بعدما تفرز صناديق الخارج لان هذه
الصناديق قد تغير في النتيجه قد تثبت
اردوغان فوق الخمسين لانه يحتاج الى خمسين
زائد واحد كي يفوز او قد ترفع من ارقام
واسهم
لنرى هذا الخبر بوثت قبل قليل اذا نتحدث
عن بشكل عام عن
85% يعني قاربنا من السته وثمانين بالمئه
من الصناديق المفرزه ولكن قبل قليل قالوا
بانه 15% فقط هي التي فرزت في خارج حتى
الان ولا نعرف اذا كان ذلك سيغير في
النتيجه ام لا اما بالنسبه الى التحالفات
ونتائج انتخابات البرلمان راويه فيمكن
القول بناء على اخر المعطيات اذا ما حدثنا
الصفحات التي لدينا بعد فرد 77 ونصف من
الصناديق التي تم فرزها ثلاثه اكثر من
ثلاثه ارباعها اذا نتحدث عن 50.9% لتحالف
الجمهور بقياده العداله والتنميه بزعامه
ودوله بهشل الحركه القوميه والرفاه الجديد
طبعا فاتح اربكان والاتحاد الكبير اضافه
الى او مقابل فقط
34.3% لتحالف الامه الذي يقوده حزب الشعب
الجمهوري وحزب الجيد ميرال اكشنار اضافه
الى تحالف العمل والحريه الذي يقوده حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي الكردي او لنقول اليسار
الاخضر كمخاض هذه الانتخابات تحت هذا
المسمى بسبب الدعاوى القضائيه ضده حصل على
9.4% اما تحالف الاجداد اتى فحصل على
الرقم غير واضح تماما امامي يعني لن اذكره
قبل ان اتاكد منه اذا هذه هي الارقام التي
لدينا حتى الان بالنسبه الى البرلمانيات
اذا ظلت الامور على هذا الحال بالنسبه الى
الانتخابات البرلمانيه فيكون حزب الجمهور
برلمانيا هو الذي فاز بقياده حزب العداله
والتنميه واذا تغيرت الاحوال في 25%
المتبقيه ربما تنقلب النتيجه لا احد يعرف
لا يمكن ان نجزم باي شيء قبل ان تفرز كل
الصناديق اما بالنسبه الى الرئاسيات فاخر
الارقام تشير كما هو كما هي الشاشه امامك
الى
85.82 بالمئه والحظ والاكبر للرئيس
اردوغان حتى الان بخمسين فاصل ثلاثه عشر
بالمئه مقابل
44.09 بالمئه فقط
لا يزال كبيرا ولكن لا نعرف ان كانت
الامور ستتغير في ال 15% فقط المتبقيه من
الصناديق انت تتحدث وكاله الاناضول
التركيه ترد على اتهامات المعارضه وتحديدا
عمده اسطنبول وتقول ان نستخدم حقنا
القانوني ض ده هو بانها ترفض الاتهامات من
عمده اسطنبول طاهر يعني
اعداد كبيره من مناصري
الرئيس التركي الحالي يحتفلون
بخارج المركز الذي تتواجد به وايضا بمراكز
اخرى
هذا صحيح في الخارج حيث نحن في هذا المقر
بدات منذ الساعات الاولى ما بعد اغلاق
صناديق الاقتراع بدات جماهير حزب العداله
والتنميه بالتوافد وبدات الاستعدادات من
على الشرفه المنصه التي تلقى عليها
الخطابات عاده ان كان من الرئيس اردوغان
ولو لم تكن خطابات الفوز يعني بالضروره
ولكن بعض الخطابات او من مسؤوليه حزب
العداله والتنميه كانت الاستعداد
الاستعدادات على قدم الوساق واستكملت
واستقبل الجمهور في خارج هذا المقر في
بحاته الخارجيه وهم يهتفون بالاغاني
يستحون بها وبالاعلام والهتافات المؤيده
للرئيس اردوغان هناك
العديد من الاخبار الجديده فيما يتعلق
ايضا بحاله الشد والجذب والاخذ والرد هذه
التي ذكرتها فيما يتعلق بنائب رئيس حزب
العداله التنميه الذي يتحدث عن التقدم في
الانتخابات البرلمانيه برلمانيه والرئاسيه
وايضا عن رفض جميع انواع الاتهامات كما
ذكرتي والدعاءات التي لا اساس لها واننا
نعلن اننا سنستخدم حقوقنا القانونيه على
اكمل وجه ضد جميع الاتهامات والادعاءات
التي تحتوي على معلومات مضلله اضافه الى
قوله هذه هذا الشقه التي الذي ذكرتيه قبل
قليل ولكن علي احسان
شؤون الانتخابات في حزب العداله والتنميه
يضيف انهم يلومون المؤسسات بسبب الذعر
الذي حدث لهم في الوقت الحالي نحن متقدمون
بشكل كبير اذا هذه اخر التفاصيل فيما
يتعلق بهذه الانتخابات هل حاله التلاشن
هذه ستبقى قائمه الى ما بعد الانتخابات
اعلان النتيجه وبالتالي سندخل في مرحله
الطعون واتهامات متبادله وعدم اعتراف
بالنتيجه ام ان الطرف الخاسر سيعترف
بالنتيجه وتنتهي الانتخابات عند هذا ام
اننا سنذهب الى جوله اعاده في الثامن
والعشرين من مايو تبقى كل الاحتمالات
قائمه الان وصلنا الى
87.63 من الصناديق المفرزه راويه في
الشاشه يمكن ان نلاحظ بوضوح هذا الرقم
ومنها خمسين
فاصل صفر واحد فقط بالمئه للرئيس اردوغان
معروف ان الرابح يحتاج الى خمسين زائد
واحد اذا ظلت هذه الارقام بالتناقص فاننا
سنكون ذاهبين الى جوله اعاده الا حصلت
مفاجات في لحظات الاخيره حتى بعض المرشحين
يتحدثون عن احتماليه الذهاب الى جوله
ثالثه الثانيه نعم مثل ما ذكرت اصوات
المغتربين الاتراك لم تحسم بشكل كبير او
بشكل نهائي حتى الان واذهب الى مراسلنا
بانقره زيدان زين كروزيدان يعني هل هنالك
من مخاوف امنيه تحذيرات
واستعدادات في حال اعلان النتائج ويعني
فوز طرف
ومناصريه طرف الاخر وردات فعلهم
نعم قبل او يعني
بكل الاحوال قبل ان انتقل الى موضوع
الاحتياطات الامنيه اتحدث هنا عن اخر
التحديثات ذكر قبل قليل الزميل طاهر بان
النسبه وصلت الى
87% لكن انا اتابع الان القناه الرسميه
الحكوميه تي ار تي تحدثت ان النسبه وصلت
الى
91.10% نسبه الاصوات او الصناديق الاقتراع
التي تم اقرصها النسبه الان
للرئيس رجب طيب ابو كان كما قالها زميلي
طاهر
50.01% اي ان الامور باتت تاخذ منعطف اخر
كمال كل جدار اوغلو
44.21% سنان اوغان
50.30% ايضا اريد ان اصحح معلومه كنت
ذكرتها قبل قليل بان نسبه فرز الاصوات
اصوات الاتراك الخارج كانت 25% لكن تصحيحا
للمعلومه دينار رئيس اللجنه العليا
للانتخابات او المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات
قال ان نسبه الفرز وصلت الى 12% او الى
12% في هذه اصوات اتراك الخارج الرئيس
اردوغان حاز على
56.47 بينما كل جدار اوغلو حالزا على
40.03% سنان اوغان اثنان فاصله 18% محرم
انجا الذي اعلن انسحابه بعد انتهاء عمليات
التصويت في الخارج حصل على
1.32% هذه هي مجمل اخر التحديثات حتى الان
بالنسبه الى الارقام نتحدث ايضا فيما يخص
الاحتياطات الامنيه لا شك ان هناك
احتياطات امنيه كبيره في محيط الاحزاب
الرئيسيه هنا في
انقره سواء في هنا امام مقر حزب العداله
والتنميه او حتى امام مقر حزب الشعب
الجمهوري وزاره الداخليه والسلطات تركيا
اتخذت كل الاجراءات تحسبا لاي
اعتراضات او اي مظاهرات او اي اعمال ربما
تنتج تنجم بعد اعلان النتائج شبه النهائيه
وحتى النتائج النهائيه لذلك
نعم نعم شبكه مراسلينا اذا من اسطنبول
طاهر بركه وايضا كريستيانو بيصري وزيدان
زنكلو عبد القادر خربوش شكرا جزيلا
اذا مشاهدينا نذكر بنتائج الانتخابات
الرئاسيه التركيه حتى الان خمسين بالمئه
فاصل صفر واحد هي لاردوغان كليتش دور
اوغلو 44.22 ونسبه الفرز تقترب من 90% هي
87.63
بالمئه وينضم الينا عبر الهاتف المحلل
السياسي مهند حافظ اوغلو من اسطنبول اذا
سيد مهند ماذا تعني لك هذه الارقام
المتقاربه جدا بين كليتش دور اوغلو
واردوغان وهل سنذهب الى جوله ثانيه
المشاهدين نعم بالفعل هذا يدل على
الاستقطاب برمتها دليل على
ان بالفعل ربما انقسام بين من يريد
استمراريه الرئيس اردوغان بتقدم طفيف على
مرشحه المدعوم من سته احزاب اساسيه كبيره
في تركيا في المحصله هي من حيث الترتيب هي
احزاب صغيره ولكن بتكتلها وانها متنوعه
المشارب من اقصى لاقصى اليسار ايدعمون
كمال ليس ربما ربما ليس ثقه به او حب به
ولكن
[موسيقى]
الرئاسه وبالتالي يعني نحن لا نزال امامنا
حوالي ثلاثه عشره بالمئه ربما بعد
حوالي 32% من الاسواق اذا ما بقيت الامور
في ضمن هذا هذه الحدود او هذه الرنج فاننا
سوف نذهب لجوده اعاده في ثمن العشرين
ما السيناريوهات المتوقعه سيد مهند في حال
خسرت المعارضه هذه الانتخابات من يتحمل
المسؤوليه هل كمالك لتجار اوغلو كشخص
كسياسي ام انه برنامج هذه المعارضه لم
يقدم بديلا مقنعا للشارع التركي
كلاهما واضيف سببا ثالثا بان المعارضه
التركيه قد اختارت الشخص الخطا للمنافسه
في حال خسر لان كماله من حيث الخطاب
للشعب التركي الكاريزما السياسيه الحين في
الاجابات لم لموفقا بها على الاطلاق ولكن
التحالفات الضروره وعائلتكاتوريته هو نفسه
لانك سيده ميراث عندما انسحبت من الطاوله
السداسيه الاول قبل بدا الحملات
الانتخابيه كانت معترضه على شخصه لانها
تدرك انه ليس بالمنافس القول لرئيس
اردوغان في ضوء انه خسر عشر انتخابات
منافسه مع اردوغان وبالتالي هي كانت تريد
ان يكون اكرم
على الاقل هو اصغر سنا ولديه حضور لذاب
الكثير من الشرائح ليس فقط الشباب لديه
خطاب جيد لديك رزمه خطابيه صحيحه انها لا
تقارن
كبائر بشكل عام لكن هذه الاسباب كلها هي
تحملها كما تتحمله الطاوله السداسيه بشكل
اساسي لانها لم تختار الشخص الصحيح لان
يكون هو منافس اردوغان عندما نتكلم عن
الرئيس اردوغان لا نتكلم عن شخص او عن
رئيس اعتيادي شخص قادر البلاد عقدين من
الزمن عود شعبه على نوع معين من الخطاب
على كاريزما معينه والشعب التركي بطبيعته
استاذه راويه لا يحتاج الى رئيس بق
در ما يحتاج لمن فقط يدير اموره وينظمها
ويعطهم اوامر بل هو يريد قائدا حقيقيا يقف
خلفه ويتجه خلفه هذه هي طبيعه الشعب
التركي منذ القدم الشعب التركي سيد مهند
يواجه ازمه اقتصاديه حاده هناك انتقادات
كبيره للحكومه بطريقه تعاطيها مع
الزلزال مع الكارثه المدمره مع اعاده
الاعمار مع جائحه كورونا ملفات كبرى يقال
بانه اردوغان وحكومته لم تتعاطى معها
بطريقه جيده
ملفات كثيره صحيح تقف في وجه رئيس اردوغان
وهو اقار بان هناك مشكلات وانها هناك
الكثير من الملفات يجب اعاده هيكلتها وعلى
راسها الاقتصاد وامور المعيشه المواطن
الاساسيه وهذا صحيح ولكن الرئيس اردو وجه
رساله وحذر من ثمن البعض
اي التي
تركيا الحديثه الذي جعلت تركيا في تصنيف
العالمي من حيث القوه الاقتصاديه رقم 19
يعني هذا الرقم لم يكن يحلم به
اليوم مديونه
هذه الاستقلاليه التي يريدها رئيس اردوغان
وان تستمر مع وعوده
مهند اعتذر عن المقاطعه ولكن هذه الساعه
الاخباريه انتهت طبعا تغطيه العربيه
لنتائج الانتخابات التركيه مستمره مع
الزميل مع الزميل صهيب اذا الذي بات جاهزا
مساء الخير مساء الخير راويه بالفعل خبر
الساعه اذا هذه الليله انتظار النتائج اذا
وحرب الارقام بين اردوغان وكليجدار اوغلو
هل سنكون امام دور ثاني في انتخابات تجرى
بعد 15 يوم ام لا ستحسم هذه المعركه
الليله سنتابع بعد قليل مع شبكه مراسلي
العربيه تفضل
[موسيقى]
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات